hello Nottingham
thank you for being here thank you for
sharing your love for our babies
be patient with us we we all want to say
a little something
but what I want to say
is that my beautiful baby girl she
wasn't just beautiful on the outside you
must have seen her pictures across media
she was so beautiful on the inside she
was a treasured and adored child
she wanted very few things in life
she wanted to be a doctor
she wanted hockey with her Pals
she wanted to have fun
because that's what all students want
they want to enjoy themselves
and all they were doing was walking home
they were just walking home after a
night out
and like Emma says Emma Weber says
this person must face Justice
it just it just is truly so unfair
but I'll Echo what my husband said
yesterday be kind to each other look
after each other don't have Hate in Your
Hearts
say prayers for my baby girl
I can't say anymore but she did love
Nottingham
foreign
I will say one more thing just one more
thing Grace Grace love Nottingham but
she's not from Nottingham and Barnaby
love Nottingham but he's not from
Nottingham either
we're from different parts of the UK
Grace from the southeast greater London
and Barnaby from from the south
from Somerset Taunton
and there's a huge huge communities down
there also needing help there's their
friends their families so it's not
just Nottingham grieving but the the
magnitude of the grief reflects the
magnitude of the love the love we had
for her thank you
[Applause]
as Grace's younger brother
I just want to thank everyone here for
coming to remember
the Lost lives of our loved ones Barney
Grace and Ian and my family especially
for flying over means the most
Grace wasn't only just a sister to me
she was the best friend of mine my
mother my father all her friends
and all her family
and if there's only one message that
comes out of this
I urge you all to cherish every moment
you spend of your loved ones as you just
never know I know and thank you
thank you
um
I really mean I really mean it when I
say thank you for taking times out of
your busy lives to be here
and share some grief with us that really
is powerful
and I really think literally each and
every one of you who's taken the time
thank you so much means so much
we
are now three
good
and the same
for Barney's family
and they're also they were a four and
they're now three
I speak to as a broken-hearted father
I I love my grace
more than I loved anything
and I'm trying to be as strong as I can
forgive me
um
there are people in hospital as well
who injured from this attack and as
families I thought with them as well I
really hope
and wish there must be the recovery
I'd like
I'd like to thank
the uniform services who who always do
such a great job
thank you to the police thank you to the
emergency services thank you for
everyone who did so much
and that Gap that I have in my life that
was Grace
she did love Nottingham when I asked her
to come down home last week she said
few more sessions as I said yesterday
she loved going out in the old town she
absolutely adored her friends and family
this is one brilliant University Town
and this is a great University that she
went to
she had so many so many good friends and
such great memories she was so looking
forward to coming back for her second
year
and she would have been a junior doctor
serving you
and your lovely city in the hospital
here
and that's been taken away from us
but thank you so much for being here and
everyone who is doing so much for us in
the background I thank everyone who's
doing that thank you so much and thank
you
the absolute thing I'm going to say
is honestly imagine a world of just love
and no violence
just imagine that world
foreign